i have a question for your dad can i ask
your dad a question sure
okay um nick so do you uh
is it hard to know when to push chris
and motivate him
and know when to is it hard to know what
his capabilities truly are is it hard to
know when
he he's being earnest about if he's had
if he's
too tired or not like i could imagine
that might be tough to kind of know is
has that been interesting to learn
great question because he has learned
how to manipulate
all of us
he has learned when when he wants
something how to
actually put on an act and so at first
when he hit that wall i would think oh
he's done
but then i started to test him a little
bit
and i realized that that was an act
and that he could keep going and so it
was a learning experience
and i've learned how to help him
mentally
overcome a lot of what's going on in
order to help him build
a strong mental attitude that helps him
fight through
um because as you can imagine everything
i've been told iron man is 90
mental the body can handle so much more
than the mind can handle
so a lot of the training was mental it
was teaching him
how to overcome that mental pain that
hits you
um and so for him tired is pain and so
um i had to learn how to figure out when
that was real when it was and how to
deal with it
and it's been a fascinating journey last
year
teaching him mental toughness um he is
as mentally tough as anybody ever going
to meet now
wow what he had to go through to do that
iron man
um you know he essentially went from a
14 mile
sprint which is you know what a lot of
people start out with
to a 140 mile iron man in about 10
months
which is unbelievable and he did it with
all kinds of obstacles uh including that
he can't ride arrow right which is a
downward position which is about 30
more efficient than the average person
he can't ride with clip-ons on his feet
he has to ride with flat
which is another 30 percent um
and then he crashed his bike in the
middle of the race so he had to like
stand up with the blood and
the pain he got bit by fire ants and so
he
his legs were all swollen up throughout
the whole thing all of that
is about mental toughness physically he
was beat up and bruised and
everything and when he wanted to quit at
every stage he just got tougher and
tougher
and at mile 13 as he said when every
bone in his body every muscle ached
everything told him to quit
he just toughened up and mentally the
whole year was about teaching him
mentally how to overcome those obstacles
and now i know that he can handle
anything in life because mentally
doesn't matter what hits him he's not
never going to quit he knows how to
fight through it
was he always like that or it's
definitely you've noticed something that
was learned
no it's something that's been learned in
the last year he was never like that
it's been and that's the good news right
for anybody
is that you can learn mental toughness
he learned
mental toughness in the last year you
must be so proud of him huh
i think he's amazing every day he just
surprises me by how tough he is how
resilient he is
um how much he learns you know and what
a great
attitude he has uh in terms of what he
does
and what i've noticed the greatest thing
of all
is the impact he's having on other
people love you baby
yeah he's changing lives man he's he's
showing people like me and my wife
who were devastated when he was first
diagnosed with down syndrome
for 20 years we thought he couldn't do
anything now
what he's showing the world is that
there's a whole world of possibilities
out there
so yeah i'm proud of him but but i'm
just so excited about
the the mission he has um to make a
difference in the world and to help
others like him and like us
boys will miss right there which one
should be
when you were on the bike oh they were
everywhere they came to see you because
they had kids with down syndrome and
they wanted to see it
wow um people came from everywhere
did they with their kids with down
syndrome and they wanted to see if this
was real
do you feel like uh you know i noticed
even just in my own life like um you
know like i had to work so hard and even
just in comedy to get
uh a foothold of my own you know and um
then at certain points you feel like god
has he wants you to be a part of a
mission or you know like
and it's natural i think to have those
those thoughts it's normal because
you're like why has so much been
and it's not a ton but why have i been
focused on why is
you know the light of the world or
whatever or a journey of the world been
kind of like
attached to me in some way um
i can only imagine that that a lot of
that kind of happens with uh
with chris uh chris do you feel like god
has a special plan for you
yeah that's pretty cool huh
yeah prayer to make sure that
i'm gonna get a woman yeah i
think that's going to happen easy dog so
christmas
i know so what about all of those social
media posts from all the moms and dads
with kids with down syndrome that you
read all the time
what are they saying those farms
with thousands of the same
i'm the hero
to kiss another king cancer
does that make you how does that make
you feel it feels
um like i'm aspiring
everybody to recall about you ten times
higher
that's interesting man yeah you're
definitely an inspiration
um yeah i can't imagine what it's like
to feel like you're then like kind of
part of this bigger journey this bigger
picture journey of inspiring people
well i'll tell you we you know we
believe that god has his hand in this
one for chris
uh and he's using chris as a way to
give hope to a lot of others like him
and create a community of inclusion
and one because what chris is doing is
not just for down syndrome he's actually
creating a whole community around him
who people are volunteering and helping
and they're seeing how wonderful it is
to be part of
a community like that um and i tell
people
um if you don't believe that god had his
hand on this one
let me tell you a story you know before
november 7th in 2020 every full ironman
in the world was canceled
right buddy after november 7th everyone
was cancelled
but november 7th when chris was doing it
it was the only one that was on really
the only one in the world you guys had
already booked that in advance we booked
it a year in advance and we told
everybody
god's not going to let this one get
canceled wow and people said you're
crazy they're all canceled they're all
being canceled
i said yes except this one god wants
chris to do something special in this
one
so he's going to make sure this one
doesn't get cancelled and it didn't get
canceled and chris shocked the world and
so so the only one chris was registered
for is the only one that happened wow
[Music]
oh that's powerful and then everybody
told us
he's not going to handle the water
because the waves are
so big and wild i said don't worry god's
going to calm the water that day
and then he said well you know he's
going to this i said don't worry god's
going to take care of it
and we're not scared chris were you
scared or not um
at first um
i knew that they copied the uh
kept going yeah and how close is your
dad when you're actually racing do you
have someone that like
are racers allowed to have a assistant
with them yeah okay
for special olympics there's a guide
someone who's with him the whole time
okay so he had a guy dan grieb who's
been an angel sent to us to help him
through this
right and dan was like the perfect
person brought into his life
and then you know he had carlos um who's
also
um helped him carlos is a dan's a
business person in orlando carlos is a
federal judge
jennifer is an executive at disney these
are all people who came around him
who got brought to him who are the
perfect personality the perfect people
the perfect backgrounds to guide him
through this journey
and to help him do something something
big so
god had his hand in this the whole time
i'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]